hey it's Justine and today we are
checking out a brand new gimbal for your
phone this is the insta 360 flow you may
be familiar with some insta360 cameras
that I've reviewed here in the past they
just recently came out with a webcam
they have some incredible 360 cameras
but now they're getting into the gimbal
game and this has a ton of different
features three axis stabilization deep
track 3.0 foldable and portable One Step
rapid deploy auto mode AI powered
editing magnetic design built-in selfie
stick and tripod all-day battery life
and a Smart Wheel let's see what all of
those things mean and get into the
unboxing
there whoa check that oh my goodness
what the heck this looks so cool it's
like
transparent so you can see inside of it
that's a really cool feature what a
little surprise very tiny this is it
here it is
what great packaging design it just
unfolds right before my eyes and this
isn't like a little pouch
cute I've unboxed a lot of insta360
things before and this might be my
favorite
so it looks like we have the mount for
your phone right here
you've got a USBC to USB a cable and
this this is actually so cute this is a
little light that you can attach to the
top of it so if you're in low light
situations you can attach this and have
a light I'm not gonna lie I don't think
I've ever seen a gimbal come with a
little light or a little purse like look
at this we also have a little strap for
the purse I mean I'm gonna call it a
purse but you can call it a carrying
case call it what you want
who is she
look at that
super cute
say it's like a one step deploy
oh it auto turns on and everything
phone mount this also has a grip that
you can add to it that actually it helps
out a lot I have pretty small hands and
my hand fits this perfectly but the cool
thing about this is it has a built-in
tripod and an extender so if you need
more space you can just pull this bottom
out and it gives you a more comfortable
grip this also has a tripod built in
which I've not seen any gimbals with
built-in tripods I've seen foam gimbals
that have attachments that you would
also have to carry with you but this
just folds right up inside of the device
this also does have an extendable selfie
stick
What the freaking heck yes now I feel
like a lot of times people use these as
gimbals to have stable footage now I
have used them like that but I'm not
gonna lie to you A lot of times I use
these when I'm out at events or if I'm
places where I don't want to ask people
to take a photo for me I will set this
up and use these types of things to take
photos by myself I don't need anyone's
help I'm just self-sufficient so I'm
very excited to test this out in my
usual foam gimbal fashion and see if it
passes the test this is the Smart Wheel
which is kind of interesting my phone
isn't currently connected to it but with
this you'll be able to scroll and change
the different modes this is also a
joystick so that'll allow you to change
the direction of your gimbal when your
phone is connected alright let's get the
phone connected there are so many
features in this thing so I think now
it's only right that we head outside and
test it out now it's time to get some
footage with the insta360 flow I'm so
excited about testing this out because
obviously I love taking shots with my
phone and this is just kind of elevating
phone already and these ducks I don't
know what they think am am I your am I
your mom
do you think I'm your mom
do you not want us here maybe that's it
I don't understand duck so I don't know
what they're saying but the first thing
I want to try out is some of the slow
motion shots so we can go in here to
slow motion and get some slow motion
duck shots
foreign
this extends so I can get closer to the
Ducks without them feeling threatened by
my presence
I'm not a threat I'm nice
something else that's kind of cool is we
also have a wide screen mode so this
will give us a really nice cinematic
look here we go now this is also
tracking me at the same time so my face
will stay in frame as I walk to get some
shots
oh my God this is so steady
like I can just lift this up and it
still keeps me in the shot
so one of the things that I really like
is how easy it is to switch between
horizontal and vertical footage so I can
just double tap on this little button
right here on the handle and that'll
quickly switch it between horizontal and
vertical
so right now we're going to shoot a
little vertical footage I could draw a
circle around my face to make sure I
stay in frame hit record and we're off
to the else that I can also do is we can
switch this while I'm recording
you switch it to the back this is
something that I do a lot in Instagram
when I'm making Instagram stories and
you can't actually do that in the iPhone
app so this gives you that ability to
just have all of that in one clip and
like and be like oh look there's ducks
look at the Ducks there they are so like
I said this video is actually being shot
in the insta 360 app so this is where
you're able to get so much more utility
out of this device by using their
built-in features in the app the other
thing I like about having this handle is
I could do a lot of controls here and I
can even Zoom with this little wheel so
this allows me to get some close-up
shots and not even have to touch my
screen at all oh my God he's getting so
close to me look how close I can get
just zooming with the zoom wheel
yeah get that itch get that itch
you got an itch you're so freaking cute
get them
let them know
[Music]
so inside of the insta360 app this
allows you to track yourself so I can
draw a little circle around myself and I
can hit
oh that's me that's me so now that I got
my coffee it's tracking me
look at this look at this look at this
look at this look at this lady that's
following me now it sees you
wonder how far it can go
oh my God it's still going
dude I went all the way around in a
circle pretty much
okay we've reached the limit and now
we're gonna go all the way back
so I'm shooting the wide screen this is
so cool because it kind of gives you a
more cinematic look for your video but
also it's tracking me so it's like I'm
shooting a feature film by myself all
alone being able to use the rear camera
will give you higher quality footage
especially when you're tracking you can
also use the trigger to start tracking
and there is a person re-identification
feature with deep track 3.0 if your
subject happens to go out of frame is
blocked by an object or another person
when it sees that original subject it
will continue to track them super cool
this latte is so good it's a butterfly
latte
it's blue
can you see him there
so good I don't know what it's made of
hopefully not butterflies or I'm very
uncomfortable okay that was pretty cool
this can also do piano photos which is
really fun to do this wall is so
beautiful so I'm gonna see if I can get
a little piano photo we have a couple of
different options there's a 3X3 which is
what we're gonna do there's a 180 which
will give you 180 degree view and
there's also a sphere that kind of gives
you that 360 view but let's just test
out the three by three
see what we got
[Music]
there it goes
so this will give you three up three
down
so it's really going to get this whole
entire scene
[Music]
yeah we really want that table in there
you definitely want that shot
and it automatically will Stitch it and
there it is there's our photo
let's try a 188 just since we're here
oh that's going to be cool
[Music]
look how cool
that is awesome I'm really glad I tested
that out so you can also do time lapses
which is really cool and this is great
because it does have the integrated
tripod in it so you definitely need that
for time lapses but one of the cool
things that I like about time lapses is
when you go in you can actually set the
in and out points so if I wanted to
start doing a time lapse at this end and
end over here I could start over here
end here and it'll do like a gradual
little turn which is so cool something
else that I actually haven't tried yet
so I'm really excited to try this is
time shift so I don't know what this is
going to look like I have no idea so you
guys are going to be experiencing it
with me so let's go do a Time shift
shall we
[Music]
thank you
I'm so excited to see what this looks
like we just got back from our little
time shift walk so let's see what we've
got
oh this looks so cool look at me
strolling look at me having a day
that was way cooler than I thought it
was gonna be I didn't know what to
expect
should we try a shot Genie
I think we should let's see Outdoors
solo Woods walk all right tracking field
of view medium shooting skills push
forward as the subject enters the scene
from the left
yeah can you do that of course I can do
it okay I mean it's not like you're not
doing it already
[Music]
so we finished shooting our shotguni
library clip that was super easy and it
was actually really fun I love this for
beginners who might not actually know
what to shoot if they're out in these
scenarios so it really gives you this
template to make shooting and filming
really easy
[Music]
you can quickly switch between mode
types there's Auto follow pan follow and
fpv right on the dial I had so much fun
experimenting with each one of these
because they are so different that
depending upon the situation you'll
quickly learn which one is right for you
let's test out a time lapse the back of
this has a built-in tripod is super
clutch
like you don't have to carry anything
extra
suggested to deploy the tripod for a
better time lapse effect
you better believe it
all right here we go
I'm gonna film some motion tracking
playing basketball but my basketball was
flat and I couldn't figure out how to
make it unflat so instead I've got a
lightsaber
[Music]
thank you
oh oh all right well lightsabering was
really fun and this worked out really
well being able to track me and now
we're gonna test out this little
Spotlight so this plugs in right here so
this is kind of like at the base of the
gimbal where you put your phone
oh look how cool this is oh my goodness
I love it so it also has a few different
modes this will allow you to change the
color temperature to match wherever you
are you've got brightness and color
temperature so freaking cool that's nice
that's a nice little medium the other
cool thing is you can actually use this
to charge your phone so you don't need
to bring a power bank if you have this
and your phone's dying you can plug it
in look at that isn't that freaking
awesome obsessed all right let's do a
couple little tests here and see how
this works so here's what it looks like
without the spotlight on it's super easy
to use all you have to do is plug it
directly into the base right here on the
gimbal so we plug this in it's going to
turn the light on and you're going to
see a huge difference so here we are no
Spotlight get ready for the spotlight
and here it is with the spotlight the
cool thing about this is there's two
different buttons on there so you can
adjust not only the brightness but the
color temperature so right now we're at
full power brightness we can turn this
down this is the lowest setting
here's the medium setting and then we'll
turn it back to high and there's the
high setting now let's change the color
temperature so this is the warmest color
temperature so this is the cool color
temperature on the brightest setting
this is medium this is probably my go-to
I feel like because it's kind of like a
nice middle balance between the cold and
the warm this is awesome I mean how many
other gimbals come with the spotlight I
don't know of any if there are any
correct me if I'm wrong but this design
is so cool for no other reason like this
cute little Spotlight and the tiny
little tripod like this is everything
ah
[Music]
this is awesome I'm so hyped let's go
let's go film a Star Wars movie
it's time for dinner in bed maybe
tomorrow
this was so much fun to review like not
gonna lie it's kind of hard to get
excited about tech when it's something
that seems so familiar like we've seen a
ton of gimbals for phones before but the
fact that it's a 360 is really taking
this a step further is to make this a
little bit different more unique and
more user-friendly I'm so here for it
you guys want to get more information
about the insta360 flow I'll put a link
in the description where you can check
it out and also purchase a huge thank
you to insta360 for partnering with me
on this video I am so hyped about this
and can't wait to take this on my next
travel Adventure I also love how small
it is and compact it literally fits in
my yoga pants love it yoga pants pocket
just
speaker
[Music]
foreign